-I woke up this morning and I
said to myself, "I am screwed.
I'm gonna be on this show."
And I turn on the computer,
and there is a sinkhole
at the White House.
-Yeah.
-And I said, "Damn, I don't have
a sinkhole joke.
-Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's what happens
when you drain the swamp.
-There you go.
-But that's a joke
everybody would be doing.
-Do you think if you were still
doing your show,
you would make jokes about
Donald Trump every second?
-I tell ya, after watching
the opening of your show,
there would be no point in me
doing it.
Because you seem to have it
covered, my friend.
-That's -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I don't do --
All I do is Jimmy Stewart.
[ Imitating Jimmy Stewart]
"Harvey."
-That's really good.
-[ Normal voice ]
But it is Mike Pence,
and this is what troubles me
about Mike Pence.
He's the Vice President.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-He is from Indiana.
-Yeah.
-And I've been thinking about --
He looks like the guy
at a funeral home
that would try to sell you
the most expensive casket.
[ Laughter ]
That's what he is. Isn't he?
-Yeah. Yeah, very earnestly.
-Oh, yeah. No.
-You want your loved ones --
-Exactly, to spend eternity...
[ Laughter ]
How's your father-in-law?
You married a woman whose father
teaches goats to surf.
-Yes.
-How many surfing goats you got?
-Here is a picture of
my father-in-law.
I'm glad you brought it up
because when I first --
the first time as a guest
on your show,
I told a story
about at the time,
the father of a woman I was
dating and his pet goat Raisin.
And Raisin
did surf at one point.
And we talked about it
every time I came on your show.
-Right.
Now, wait a minute.
Is this your wife's father?
-That's my wife's father.
-Oh, because you said the girl
you were dating.
I thought, "Oh, crap,
I've stepped in it again."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I'm glad you said it
because I -- you know,
when I first started dating her,
I went on your show,
told this goat story.
And the next time I came on your
show, I remember them saying,
"If you have more stories
about the goat,
Dave would love to hear it."
And that's when I realized,
"I'm gonna have to stick with
this girl because I'm --
I can't run out of
goat stories. Yeah."
-But now, I was hoping coming
here tonight, I had many hopes.
[ Laughter ]
But chief among them was the --
I wanted to see the goat
actually up riding a wave.
-Well, I have some news
about the goat.
-Oh, no.
-The goat passed away.
[ Audience awws ]
Here's an obituary.
-Really?
-Yeah.
But I think you'll be very --
-"Goat that led two lives."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Words that have never
been printed
in the history of language.
-But I think
you'll appreciate this
because the goat obviously
meant so much to you.
This is -- you know,
this is in an actual obituary.
"Raisin was
a local and national celebrity
admired both by his owner
and the island community,
and a much wider audience
after he was featured on
'The Late Show
with David Letterman.'"
[ Laughter ]
So that -- you know,
that's something for you.
You made a goat's obituary.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
But to be sure,
you actually saw the goat surf?
Now, don't lie to me.
I want to know
if the goat actually surfed.
-The goat stood on a surfboard.
But I'm pretty sure
the surfboard
was more on the ground
than the wave.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, this goat passed away
everyone.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
-Don't speak ill of the dead.
-Talking about a dead goat,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Laughter ]
I got something for you, buddy.
-What do you got?
-Anybody here
ever had Lyme disease?
It's a --
I'm doing this to promote
epidemiological health
and awareness,
because the Lyme disease,
the ticks are everywhere.
I've had Lyme disease.
-You have?
-Oh, yeah.
Probably got it now.
[ Laughter ]
-You look like a guy
who would have it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I've had Ehrlichiosis.
And the third one
would be babesiosis,
and that's the hat trick.
[ Laughter ]
So, I pulled this off
my lower back Monday morning.
And he's been in this bag since.
-Oh, this is --
-These are tenacious
little bastards.
-So you brought a tick?
[ Laughs ]
-There.
-That is a --
That's a live tick.
Because now, how long was it
on you, would you say?
-At least overnight.
-Yeah.
So are you gonna have --
-But see, look,
he's still alive.
He was sealed in a Ziploc bag.
And by the way,
don't you think I get a little
money from the Ziploc people?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Come on.
Just a little --
-Are you gonna
have this tested?
Because now they can test it,
right?
And find out if it --
[ Audience groans ]
-[ Laughs ]
-What a bunch of babies.
[ Laughter ]
No, I'm not gonna
have him tested.
He's yours.
-Oh, wow.
You know --
-You have him tested.
You're the man with the show.
[ Laughter ]
-I could use my budget.
-Yeah, that's right. Yeah.
-Well, I have to be honest.
Of all the gifts
anyone's ever brought,
and I thought, you know,
what I really thought,
I owed you for the legacy
of this show
and the fact that
if you hadn't started,
I wouldn't be here,
but really --
-You know, I keep forgetting
about that
because your show
is nothing like my show.
My show was lumpy and viscous.
-Beautifully so.
-And your show is crisp
and smart and contemporary.
And it's just lovely, so --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He agrees.
-You're the fifth host
of this show.
-Fourth.
-Fifth.
"Tomorrow Show" -- Tom Snyder.
-Oh, right. Yep.
-Then myself, then Conan,
then Jimmy Fallon, and now you.
-Yeah. And you think tomorrow --
you think a better show title
would have been
"The Tomorrow Show"?
-Absolutely.
Because Pat Weaver, a gentleman
who is Sigourney Weaver's father
worked at NBC in, I think,
promotion,
and had this strategy of
"Today," "Tonight"
and "Tomorrow."
And I begged you
when you took over this show --
-You did.
-Change it!
But anyway, why not
"The Tomorrow Show"?
-Yeah, it's -- you know,
I -- I thought about it.
But you what it was?
It meant a lot to me to be
another host of "Late Night."
-Oh, God bless you.
Isn't he the nicest man
in the world?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I really appreciate you
being here.
I really appreciated this.
We're gonna keep it.
I'm gonna give to it
the next host of this franchise,
whenever that happens.
-Great success.
-David Letterman, everybody!